Imagine you decide to try and navigate through a life-sized maze.
Personally, I have no sense of direction and easily get lost, confused, and
frustrated.
In fact, I'd probably rather sit alone for an hour and just think and do nothing
than try to make it through a maze alone.
But if you had to go through a maze, what would make it easier to navigate?
Well, a guide would be helpful. It could help us know which steps to take as we try
to get through the maze. A compass would be really nice.
In fact, a compass would probably prevent us from getting lost, which is probably
what would happen to me. Or a map would be super helpful, because a map would help
us know exactly the path to be on from beginning to end.
Essentially, what we would be looking for is someone or something to help us make it
through the maze safely. We
constantly make choices every day based on our worldview.
Choices about how we treat people, how we spend our money, how we spend our time,
whether we believe in God or not.
And these choices lead us on a certain path.
And in the end, we find ourselves at a specific destination.
Now, there's no physical map for the maze of life, but we all have a mental map, a
worldview, which is a set of beliefs that we have that helps us interpret the world
around us. How accurate and live in reality.
So here's the critical question.
How accurate is your mental map of reality?
Your worldview?
I mean, think about it. If you have a physical map and it doesn't match up, you're
going to get lost and confused. But if your map does match up, you can make it
through the maze successfully. We all carry around ideas which are part of our
worldview, which shape our daily choices.
Whether you're a Christian, an atheist, Buddhist, a Hindu, we all have a belief
system that shapes the way that we live.
You see, the question is not, do we have a worldview?
The question is, what is our worldview and where did it come from?
From friends? From tradition? From family?
From culture? Where does our worldview originate?
With all these influences on our worldview, it's going to be critical to take a
moment and examine our belief system more carefully.
There
are a lot of different ways to examine the concept of a worldview and our own
worldviews in particular.
Perhaps most helpful will be to consider four big questions that every worldview
has to answer. First, what is real?
What exists? Is reality only the physical world that we can touch, taste,
see, and feel? Or is there a spiritual realm beyond the physical world?
Is a human being just a body? Or is there also a soul?
Second, what is man? What does it mean to be human?
Are we the product of blind evolutionary forces within nature?
Or are we a part of the larger God consciousness and interconnected with all of
reality? Or are we the personal creation of loving God who made us
in His image? Third, what happens at death?
Where do we go, if anywhere, when we die?
Maybe this is all there is, and that death is final.
When your heart stops beating, that's it.
Or maybe you enter into some state of reincarnation until you finally reach nirvana.
Or maybe when you die, you face judgment before God and go to either heaven or hell
for eternity. Every belief system has some claim about what happens when we
die.
And fourth, what is the basis for right and wrong?
Where does morality come from? Some believe that morality is relative, that there's
no absolute standard outside of us, and that right and wrong comes from the
individual or society. Others would point to karma, that we get rewarded or punished
from actions we've done in the past, and they carry on into the future.
Whereas others believe that there's a standard outside of us, an objective standard
that comes from either God's character or God's commands, which determines right
from wrong. So why bother to think so deeply about our worldview?
As Christians, isn't our worldview already set?
Well, interestingly, and very importantly, studies show that people who describe
themselves as Christians, in other words, they check that box on a survey, live no
differently from people who do not.
But there's a segment of people who describe themselves as Christians that live
differently. It's the Christians with a biblical worldview.
So that means if you want to live with the power of the gospel in your life, you
need to see the world through the lens that Jesus saw it.
If you see the world as Jesus did, in terms of our four big worldview questions and
more, you'll be far more likely to live like Jesus.
And if you live the way that Jesus wanted you to, you'll be far more likely to
experience the freedom that he promised to those who follow him on the path of life.